let's go next to zayler from rhode
island sailor from rhode island you're
on the air
zayler from rhode island yes sorry it
took me a while to meet myself
how are you doing today david i'm doing
well thank you
so you did a video actually very
recently
about dog whistles and you discuss dog
whistles used on the right
and dog whistles that might be used as
on the left and you mentioned that
some of the leftist dog whistles are
either boring or there's not too many of
them
um i i didn't see you mention though
sometimes i feel like
even the word use of the word elite can
be
considered a dog whistle by both the
right and the left usually on the right
it's referring to like their hatred of
jewish people on the left uh the
extremists sometimes just use it as like
a catch-all for like capitalists like
um just like capitalist in general uh
some of the more socialist types use it
in that way
oh what do you think about that i don't
you know so you're certainly right
that sometimes when the left uses the
term elites they're talking about
economic elites which applies to rich
people and corporate ceos and that type
of thing
i guess i don't i'm not saying i don't
know that it's a dog whistle in the
sense that everybody understands what
they mean by that one of the things
about dog whistles is when you blow a
dog whistle the dog hears it but you
know humans don't really hear it
so i just would disagree that it's it's
definitely a co it's coded language but
it's coded language everybody seems to
sort of understand so i don't know that
elites
in that usage really counts as a dog
whistle
that makes sense actually that now that
you mentioned that
excellent well that's really the only
question i had
prepared so i just hope you have i'm
hope you're doing well and keeping warm
thank you yes zayler from rhode island
appreciate the call remember everybody
the lesson from uh
from zayler there is always make sure
to set your discord to silent or do not
disturb or whatever it is so we don't
hear those annoying noises